from the top of this 45 meter drop tower
my friends from the how ridiculous
YouTube channel are about to release a
watermelon for you yet
in freefall for a full 3 seconds the
watermelon accelerates to over a hundred
kilometers per hour before smashing into
the ground
the results are predictable but this was
just a control for the actual experiment
another watermelon it was sprayed with a
polymer coating we'll come back to what
this is and how it works but for now
let's see how the coated watermelon
fares in the drop test instead of
shattering the watermelon bounces and
remains intact for the most part anyway
is it broken inside yeah
even with an axe the how ridiculous boys
can't crack this shell
that is amazing it is pretty amazing
that the watermelon could survive an
impact at over a hundred kilometers per
hour so I went to find out more about
the coating called line-x
it's a mess the individual components
are a mess when it goes on it goes on as
a big mess you saw me wear a spray suit
it's the best but when you're done your
really cool stuff line-x is made from
two ingredients a and B inside of each
of these is multiple things but the main
component of a is diphenyl methane for
four diisocyanate or MDI for short it's
very reactive due to these groups on the
end B is the poly so the simplest way I
could explain is it's a plasticizer the
main component of B is alpha 2 amino
methyl ethyl Omega 2 amino methyl ethoxy
polyoxymethylene to ethane Dial long
name for a long chain molecule in
reality it would be many times longer
than this now I managed to convince Bryn
to let me mix the two ingredients the
old-fashioned way with the stir stick I
say hey wow I'm gonna dump a and B in
here and just mix them and see what
happens all right okay ready yep go for
it
how quickly should they react they're
reacting right now did you see that that
is crazy and you can see there's almost
like I don't know smoke or something
well it's probably getting quite warm I
guess I could have got the thermometer
out for you whoa let me feel the bottom
tell me you tell me yeah that's very hot
it's like the bottom of a hot oh very
hot very hot yeah what's happening here
is the molecules of a and B are reacting
to form long chains where they join they
form a urea group so the substance is
called a polyuria the structure of these
chains is responsible for the properties
of the coding so it's hard because it's
made of a tangled mess of molecular
threads but flexible because these
threads can be stretched out and then
snapped back into place things you
learned doing the reaction this way are
that it's rapid only taking seconds to
react and it's exothermic a lot of heat
is given off as these bonds form but
this bottle of line-x
isn't really useful for much so how do
you mix a and B to form an effective
coating put them really high pressure
force them together in a really small
space high temperature high pressure
just Ram them into each other that
essentially mixes them and then they
come out the end of the gun so from the
time their separate components they mix
out the gun hit your target fraction of
a second this is where the magic happens
inside here pull the trigger outcomes
line-x
we decided to linacs a piece of paper to
see how strong the coding is
as you can see it came out as a hot
high-pressure liquid okay now it's it's
quite warm and because that's an
exothermic reaction it comes out at 150
but it keeps getting hotter and hotter
you can probably rip it right now yeah I
think so no okay all right those two
chemicals just keep kind of looking for
each other or looking for something so
to speak until until every last
molecules found a home or given up
looking and I could take a day or more
but there's plenty of opportunities to
cross link right now so that's what it's
doing and that's where all the heats
coming from so it's already dry I'm not
gonna get any on me yeah it's already
cooling back down so we've done the vast
majority of curing and cross-linking
yeah we're getting we're getting there
right yeah we're getting there it was
harder so now we'll wait to some of this
heat goes away bro we're probably
getting a good amount of curing going on
it is really tough to rip at this it's
strong stuff says that tensile strength
will get you that high tensile strength
is the same reason the line-x coated
watermelon bounces as it hits the ground
the contents of the watermelon are
squeezed out sideways but the tangle of
polyuria molecules pull together
preventing the rind of the watermelon
from deforming too much and breaking
apart so the watermelon bounces instead
of smashing this type of coating is now
used in the walls of the Pentagon
preventing exterior explosions from
launching shrapnel into the building the
main cause of injury from explosions and
it's used in bulletproof vests to
contain bullet fragments that could
cause serious injury all of this is
pretty incredible for a substance
invented as a truck bedliner yeah come
on down bring your entire vehicle
anything but your cat will line exit
massive thanks to the guys over at the
how ridiculous YouTube channel you know
they're the ones that launched that
basketball off the dam that is my most
popular video and they have been doing
some incredible experiments like bowling
ball versus axe so go subscribe to their
channel go do it right now